hello
my name is keith lee and i am the game
director for godfall
on behalf of counterplay games we are
very excited to share gameplay with you
today
and to offer you a glimpse into the
mystical world of godfather
today you'll be seeing extensive
gameplay captured on a playstation 5
development kit
please keep in mind that the game is
still a work in progress
and some things may change from the
final product as we continue to learn
and harness the power of sony's next
generation console
please enjoy
so let's jump right into what godfall is
godfall is a looter slasher that
features intense action
satisfying moment-to-moment combat and
robust
loot progression systems you can enjoy
the game at your own pace
playing alone or through online co-op
with up to two
additional teammates godball is set in a
brand new
high fantasy universe filled with heroic
knights
arcane magic and forbidden realms
the world is split up into the elemental
realms of
earth water
air and fire godfall
is a complete package all loot and gear
in the game
are acquired or unlocked through
gameplay
there are no micro transactions no
waiting for content
it's all in the game on day one
as you adventure you'll get to tear
through enemies to challenge
a mad god who awaits you at the top
you play a valorian knight a godlike
warrior
able to equip valor plays legendary
armor sets that transform you
into an unstoppable master of melee
combat
throughout your journey you'll find
ancient valor plates lost in time
each with their own characteristics and
long history
now let's talk about gameplay in godfall
first our team wanted to do something
different
we wanted to combine action rpg loot
progression
with third person melee combat to create
what we think
is a looter slasher
our game is therefore one part gear
driven and
one part player skill driven in other
words
not only do we want you to find
exquisite weapons with powerful loot
rates
but we also want you to have that
feeling of accomplishment
from mastering the wide set of combat
mechanics available to you
in godfall from a combat philosophy
perspective
the melee combat godfall is intended to
be fluid
dynamic and interactive embracing
offense
over defense more often than not you'll
be facing multiple enemies
at the same time as a result you should
always be moving
and closing the gap on enemies also
you dominate the combat space not the
enemies
and the game rewards you for being
aggressive
now that you're familiar with the combat
philosophy let's dig into the weapons
themselves
in godfall there are five weapon classes
the longsword
the dual blades
the pole arm
the two-handed warhammer
[Music]
and the two-handed green sword
each weapon class has their own unique
movesets and play styles ranging from
fast combos to more strategic deliberate
play
as you defeat enemies in your adventures
you will acquire
numerous weapons for each weapon
category
each weapon with their own primary and
secondary
traits at a later date we will delve
into the weapon classes
and how to modify them in greater detail
for now
we'll go over the dual blades and the
long sword
weapon classes the dual blades are the
fastest weapon class
in godfall embodying speed fluidity and
mobility
the dual blades are exceptional against
soft unarmored targets or single targets
you can perform a combo by executing
four consecutive light attacks
the dual blades heavy attack is a
spinning blade cyclone
the blade cyclone can also be used as a
finisher
at the end of your light attack combo so
what are the signature moves for the
dual blades
as you build up charge you can also
activate inner focus
which is unique to the dual blades which
inflicts massive damage
in a short period of time there's also a
mortal coil
where you can throw your blade into an
enemy pulling the enemy towards you
like pulling a cable
now let's switch to the longsword weapon
class
longswords are balanced weapons
embodying crisp
damage and simple cooldowns without
needing a lot of elaborate combo setups
similar to dual blades long swords have
their own 4 hit
light attack combo then there's the
heavy attack finisher
which can be used at the end of your
light attack combo
there are three signature moves for the
long sword class
there's spectral flurry which cannot be
interrupted and deals high damage to
multiple nearby targets
then there's spiral technique which
eviscerates all enemies
in a straight fixed path notice there's
a white flash
after a long sword swing called a timing
attack if you press the shield button
exactly at the same time you'll perform
a devastating
shield uppercut with your longsword the
shield
is a core part of godfall it's available
to you
throughout the entire game you can
always block
incoming attacks with your shield if you
press the shield button at the right
time
you can also parry and attack you can
perform a light attack
after a last second shield block to
counter attack with a powerful
shield strike the shield is great not
just for defense
but also offense you can aim and throw
your shield
which will hit multiple nearby targets
if you tap the shield button
just as you catch your shield you can
perform a powerful wave attack
you can double tap the shield button to
petrify enemies
and of course you can perform an r3
ground finisher on enemies that were
knocked down to the ground
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we hope you enjoyed our first walk
through video of godfall running on the
playstation 5.
we also want to thank all the fans for
their endless support since our initial
reveal back in december
we have a few more surprises coming down
the road such as details on loot
and progression and are eager to share
more with you on our way to launch this
holiday season
we hope that you will join our godfather
community on twitter
facebook and youtube thank you
[Music]
you